[Musik]
in der engadiner bergwelt liegt das
hochalpine institut fan
hier lernen und wohnen schüler von nah
und fern
zeva aus sankt petersburg befindet sich
im letzten jahr des gymnasiums
schulkollegin batliner wohnt in school
und besucht die sportklasse
auch für robin aus der innerschweiz
finden sich nun die weichen fürs leben
ein team von internetbetrügern kümmert
sich um die freuden und sorgen der
jugendlichen
und gerhard steuble amt als rektor des
traditionsreichen instituts für alle ist
es das jahr der entscheidungen
[Musik]
olympia fieber im hochalpinen institute
ins tal schon zwei goldmedaillen hat der
bekannteste absolvent der schule
gewonnen langläufer dario cologna nun
läuft er gemeinsam mit seinem bruder
gianluca dem team springt
auch wenn die colonias in diesem
turbulenten rennen nicht ganz nach vorne
fahren die olympischen spiele sind eine
willkommene ablenkung für alle denn das
institut durchlebt derzeit schwierige
zeiten
in der letzten sendung der
internatsschule tann fand in der aula
noch eine aussprache statt zwischen
schülern und einer journalistin in
einem zeitungsartikel wurde das
hochalpine institut und die schulleitung
rund um rektor steuble massiv kritisiert
[Musik]
situation hardliner gaudenz trainierte
für ihr großes ziel den engadiner
frauenlauf mit seinen 1000
teilnehmerinnen
und silber puschkin lieferte sein matura
poster auf den allerletzten drücker
allerdings wurde es nur mit einer
ungenügenden noten bewertet
[Musik]
mächtig steht es da das hochalpine
institut 100 jahre alt ist das gebäude
in dieser ära gab es viele sonnige
zeiten aber auch manche stürme zogen
über die schule doch in diesem winter
trägt sich hier oben einmaliges zu
die schule von rektor gerhard stäbler
wird in einer serie von zeitungsartikeln
heftig kritisiert viermal in folge war
das institut auf der frontseite der
größten bündner tageszeitung von
disziplinarischen schwierigkeiten und
ungeahndeten absenzen ist die rede
auslöser der berichterstattung war der
brief eines von steuble entlassenen
lehrers
auch die heutige schlagzeile dreht sich
um die schule der schwerwiegendste
vorwurf lautet dass am hochalpinen
institut abschlussnoten manipuliert
würden zugunsten der zahlenden
internatsschüler dekra manipulation der
system controller sind so hoch wie
erwartet den abschluss präfektur
cantorum begleitet und safe experten
unterschreibt am schluss abschluss
platte berührt in autos werden aber
verglichen mit einzeln einfach die trag-
und damit ist kein spielraum für
manipulation
rektor schäuble hat insgesamt 130
schüler an seinem institut
einer von ihnen ist im stress
zeva proschkin
ja muss jetzt noch
ganz fertig sein der russe hatte über
ein halbes jahr zeit um seine matura
arbeit zu schreiben nun bleiben ihm nur
noch zwei tage
ich habe noch nicht ganz so de inhalte
zeichen ist und wer ist das dann anfangs
platte entblättert und des logos und das
hab ich noch alles nicht ich hab nur
nach text dann schicke jetzt wächst und
dann zwei nächte mal gecheckt entweder
oder heute abend schickten sagt
vielleicht das ist nicht ganz wichtig
und dann muss nach jedem ich mache mache
ich morgen heute noch einmal etwa
sondern in voller breite abgeben
und ja er kann nicht verändern
der 18 jährige hat ein anspruchsvolles
thema gewählt wie kann man mit
augenbewegungen computer steuern
gc war die arbeit nicht rechtzeitig ab
sie die folgen fatal er darf dann nicht
an den maturaprüfungen teilnehmen
rektor steuble verzichtet auf sein
mittagessen die kritischen
zeitungsartikel liegen ihm auf den magen
denn sie treten ihnen die übrige
schulleitungen persönlich
[Musik]
trübe aussichten auf der loipe
die stimmung passt zu den schwierigen
zeiten direktor steuble durchmacht er
kann nur erahnen wohin der weg führt und
ein ende ist nicht absehbar
doch ungeachtet der sorgen und nöte der
schulleitung nimmt das leben im internat
des hochalpinen instituts seinen
gewohnten gang
[Musik]
ein
die große passion von robin fix ist die
elektronische musik mit seinem computer
kann robin ganze musikalische welten
erschaffen in seinem kleinen zimmer im
vierten stock der zentrale
zum glück wie
zum vor der musikverlage eines tages
habe so nicht möglich an machen
es ist ja so langsam richtig machen also
für sie ringen das musikmachen finden
empfindet sie jetzt etwas
wirklich machen aber für mich ist halt
hobby
leidenschaft und berichten irgendeines
mal job zusammen und das hoffe ich
halten können zwar wieder alles zu sagen
[Musik]
nach dem schulabschluss will robin ein
zwischenjahr einlegen und sich voll auf
die musik konzentrieren schon heute
verdient er als dj ein wenig geld für
das nächste wochenende hat er seine
eigene party geplant unten in seiner
heimat nicht walten
[Musik]
internat mitarbeiterin ruth berlau ist
eingeteilt für die nachtschicht sie
trägt die verantwortung für 65 internats
bewohner und muss ein stattliches areal
unter kontrolle haben sie macht einen
rundgang durch den mädchen trakt
in diesem zimmer erwartet ruth bei jena
eine überraschung
das mädchen hat die decke und das kissen
so hingelegt dass es bei flüchtigem
blick scheint als ob jemand im bett lege
[Musik]
bei jeder macht sich auf die suche es
ist nicht das erste mal dass dieses
mädchen zur schlafenszeit nicht im
zimmer ist
[Musik]
drüben den buben trakt hat ihr kollege
grant fletcher aufsicht
[Musik]
brauchen ist nur an einem ort erlaubt
im winter müssen sich die raucher ihre
zigaretten regelrecht erfrieren
[Musik]
doch auch draußen in der klirrenden
kälte keine spur von dem mädchen
[Musik]
weder kontrolliert noch mal das zimmer
des mädchens
doch es ist noch immer leer
drüben im schulgebäude rektor gerhard
stoll ist in letzter zeit länger im haus
als üblich die kritischen
zeitungsartikel bescheren ihm viel
gesprächs arbeit mit eltern lehrern und
schülern
auf der fahrt nach hause bleibt stoiber
zeit alles durchzudenken bis hin zur
unheilvollen möglichkeit dass sein
eigener job in gefahr sein könnte
im moment
von tag zu tag
ich will einfach nicht dass man dass man
so quasi auf stufe 2 seine patienten
die stufen ist einfach dass mir
beurteilung nicht erreicht der
schienenbus der beurteilung von anderen
stern ist ja absolut
aber ich mag ihn sehr und ich weiß wie
schnell
das land halt stopp loss ungewissheit
wie es weitergeht wird bald ein ende
haben eine verwaltungsratssitzung ist
angekündigt
[Musik]
rothweiler gibt entfernung das verlorene
mädchen ist wieder aufgetaucht sie war
unerlaubterweise im bogen trakt als man
sie sucht er versteckte sie sich mit
schlechtem gewissen im waschraum
[Musik]
okay
für ihren verstoß gegen die hausregeln
bekommt das mädchen einen gemeinnützigen
dienst auf verlegt das
wird ihr ruht bei ja aber erst morgen
mitteilen
sieht doch lieber
ruhig
und
versteck
im vierten stock
[Musik]
am wochenende in school
die mutter von marina gaudenz verstaut
die beinprothese ihrer tochter im auto
auf diesen tag haben beide hingefiebert
der engadiner frauenlauf findet statt
die präparierung der langlauf skis hat
die mutter übernommen
das ist
leider läuft das rennen mit einer etwas
längeren prothese als jener welche sie
im alltag trägt seit geburt hat man
kleiner ein verkürztes rechtes bein
gleichwohl lässt sie es sich nicht
nehmen wettkampfsport zu betreiben
wo mir zu machen
rund 1000 teilnehmerinnen sind beim
frauenlauf am start weiner hat sich zum
ziel gesetzt in das vorderste drittel zu
laufen trotz ihrer behinderung
[Musik]
im vierten stock des internets steht
noch jemand vor einem rennen gegen die
zeit
[Musik]
leverkusen ist eben aufgestanden
bis morgen muss er seine maturaarbeit
fertig haben
der wille sich an die matura arbeit zu
machen wäre da doch mit der umsetzung
hapert es immer tut sich schwer mit
selbstdisziplin und da seine eltern 2000
kilometer entfernt in sankt petersburg
wohnen fehlt ihm auch jemand der ihn
antreibt
[Musik]
eigentlich wie ich
und dann stehe ich im film
aber dann mache ich das sind
dann ja also ich kann schon das zeit gut
verwenden können neben kupfer aber
nachher ist das dann für mich schwierig
das zu erledigen ich denke ich kann das
schon erledigen aber da kommt noch ein
faktor zu müssen was machen dann muss
sie noch nicht sehe dann muss ich noch
ein handy schneller das schau und dann
noch
robin fix verlässt das internat
er hat sich für dieses wochenende
einiges vorgenommen
in der nähe seines wohnortes in
nidwalden veranstaltet robin eine party
für etwa 300 leute
[Musik]
in saanen ist der start des engadiner
frauenlaufs die ganze familie gaudenz
ist versammelt auch papa du ri und
schwester
die schwester wohnt mit der mutter in
der nähe von chur während matt liner bei
ihrem vater liebt einen pensionierten
arzt dass die ganze familie gemeinsam
unterwegs ist passiert nicht allzu oft
die frau hat immer viel los
[Musik]
werden sie
jetzt schon früher nach einiger zeit kam
für den bin ich
nur noch wenige minuten bis zum start
batliner ist nicht zum ersten mal beim
frauenlauf dabei und doch ist sie
aufgeregt
für den frauenlauf sind sogar olympia
teilnehmerinnen gemeldet
batliner startet im ersten block ganz
zuvorderst
sie ist die einzige die mit einer
prothese läuft
diese kundschaft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein kleiner bewegt sich nur mit
kräftigen stößen vorwärts sie kann sich
nicht mit den beinen abstoßen wie die
anderen
das rennen zieht sich über 17 kilometer
batliner gibt eine stunde vollgas
[Musik]
1200 meter tiefer instanz ist der winter
schon
passiert
hier landen
robin pickles dekoriert mit freunden den
partizan
ja gar nicht so nicht besetzt weil ich
schätze vier party und
später zum krieg von uns sieht weiß man
wie es hieß seien laut
tettens heißt die party robin rechnet
mit ziemlich vielen gästen
[Musik]
robin hat den saal gemietet einladungen
gestaltet sicherheitsleute organisiert
und im verlaufe der nacht will er als dj
auch noch selber plattenauflegen
[Musik]
partys organisieren und
vertrieb der eigenen diskurs randaliert
das ist vielleicht mal ein traum vor dem
großen drang das massaker
ja
schwester erreicht mit leider die letzte
zwischen verpflegung
[Musik]
nach einer stunde drei minuten und 58
sekunden
erreicht magna das ziel ist scharf
[Musik]
die mutter ist bereits im ziel
schon lange hier mama bereit umgezogen
nein ich bin auch jetzt gerade
angekommen habe eben die kleider
gewechselt
tätowierer astra gespielt sein die
nummer möchte ich gerne behalten
[Applaus]
ehemann dury kommt gratulieren hast du
mich gesehen ja klar du hast mich
angeschaut hat sich nicht angefeuert war
ich hab dich erst hier gesehen
die mutter von matt liner wird dritte in
ihrer kategorie batliner übertrifft ihr
ziel sie lässt 800 frauen hinter sich
und klassiert sich als sechster in ihrer
altersgruppe
[Musik]
schäfer puschkin ist immer noch mit
seiner maturaarbeit beschäftigt
doch langsam scheint er sich einem ende
zu nähern
[Musik]
im internet entdeckt sie war weitere
interessante informationen die er in
seinen text einfließen lassen will
es ist der allerletzte abend an dem er
noch an seiner maturaarbeit feilen kann
[Musik]
robin hat seine arbeit schon lange
abgegeben und kann sich um seine party
kümmern
[Musik]
läuft alles
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
ist bereit die gäste können kommen
[Musik]
doch es kommt niemand die tanzfläche
bleibt leer
ernüchterung bei robin und seinen
freunden
[Musik]
meine gemeldet
merkel sagte
mit den handys spricht es sich
heutzutage schnell herum wo etwas läuft
partybesucher sind herdentiere und die
erde kommt heute nicht an robbins party
der nimmt es mit humor
[Musik]
auch später in der nacht wird es nicht
besser die party ist ein flop robben
wird einen finanziellen verlust zu
tragen haben
die größte frisches personal
ja es muss ich meinen tag so ziemlich
jeden in gang gekommen danach liefen die
maschinen dann gibt's mal so viel
[Musik]
mit den kleinen gewürze sind
bekam ich aber
dass fast liebevoll mit der partys nicht
statt hit happens heißt es für robin an
diesem abend schiebt hätten
[Musik]
und jetzt ist dort niemand das ist
ein dämpfer für robin doch seinen traum
der einst von der musik leben zu können
gibt er deswegen nicht auf
[Musik]
oben beim hochalpinen institut
ruth berlau hat feierabend am frühen
morgen
nach der nachtschicht darf sie nun nach
hause
[Gelächter]
endlich springt er an
[Musik]
rektor gerhard stäbler hat die
lehrerschaft zu einer sitzung versammelt
brennendes thema nach wie vor die
kritischen zeitungsartikel
sondern es ist bis heute nicht in der
zeitung sehen jetzt da ich möchte dass
ein bisschen symbolisch jetzt wirklich
machen für mich sind das tempi passati
und ich will das jetzt bewusst
und
ich hoffe dass wir jetzt wirklich durch
diese zeit hindurch miteinander das
geschafft haben ich habe auch schon mal
gesagt mittelsleute und nicht jede
belastung die dadurch erfahren habt wenn
ihr antworten geben müssen fragen wo man
nicht immer so leicht antwort kann
jemand hat mir gesagt am schluss wächst
man aufgrund von solchen dingen zusammen
und ich habe viele zeichen bekommen um
zusammenzuwachsen und
ich lege das jetzt beiseite und für mich
ist es soweit
erledigt
[Musik]
eine andere angelegenheit ist definitiv
noch nicht erledigt im boden internat
begeben sich der leiter des internats
und ein lehrer in den vierten stock die
frist um die matura arbeit abzugeben ist
verstrichen
nun wird die arbeit persönlich bei sega
eingefordert
schläft noch
physiklehrer georg steinwender ist der
experte welcher sei was arbeit betreut
er wird sie auch bewerten müssen
dann schaue ich sie dann aber ich dann
machen wir so durch damit man keine
probleme haben im schicken spielen was
bitte darf denn auf den stick hinauf
dann schaue ich das dann gleich an
aber das kann inhalt sind dabei am
anfang das ist so gar nicht
es muss aber alles dabei sein das ist ja
schon klar aber
dann bist du jetzt aufstehen müssen und
dann den rest noch fertig machen müssen
ich brauche alles die arbeit muss jetzt
ich musste ja jetzt bewerten
ja ich habe jetzt unterricht schaue dass
ich dann in der ersten pause das 1 x
kurzsichtige weiter dass nur die kopiert
ist möchte das anschauen und dann du
musst also den rest noch da das ist doch
noch zu wenig ich schaue auch ist es
gleich mit dem was du schon einmal
gegeben hast wo ich dir gesagt haben das
ist nicht in ordnung das muss ich jetzt
mal als anschauen so einfach ist das
auch nicht das kann ich nicht in fünf
minuten sagen okay
zur gleichen zeit im sitzungsraum der
internatsschule der verwaltungsrat des
hochalpinen instituts trifft sich zu
einer sitzung
die schule ist als aktiengesellschaft
organisiert
präsident ist professor doktor rolf dubs
der auch durch die sitzung führt
es ist die erste zusammenkunft seit der
artikelserie über die angeblichen
versäumnisse am institut die
berichterstattung wurde durch einen
brief eines ehemaligen lehrers ins
rollen gebracht
rektor gerhard steuble scheint nervös zu
sein
[Musik]
70 wohin sie jetzt informationsbedarf so
dass der rektor ulrich können auskünfte
teile der staaten
was ist wahrheit geworden
dass ich nur mal wahrscheinlich passiert
auch jede spur das line-up alles nochmal
verrückt ist oder was immer stoppen
würden
sowieso mitglieder blass und nutzen
von elena die
erste kunst fragen nicht der vorwurf vor
der note
manipuliert zugunsten der reichen und
der vorwurf von tim ich reagiere beruf
für folgt aus jetzt also
universitätsrektor wie mir ist es immer
zog sie das motto not konferenz jeder
schüler besprochen wenn eine knapp
beurteilt die zukunftsaussichten
und lehrerschaft eigentlich dass die
zukunftsaussichten gut sind dennoch
ereigneten
die vorgabe dass er gar keine antwort
aus - direkt vor
ihr schon vor altenkunstadt
reformplan potenzial verschickt hat mir
ist ein unbekannter täter unmittelbar
ans andere welt geschickt und sonntag
dass es so geworden dass das von 1000
euro und hat dann weggeht und jetzt
waren wir nicht reagieren bis jetzt
gesprochen worden sind dennoch passen
das ist jetzt glaubte jetzt passiert ist
aber immer der gleiche inhalt umgehen
kann und da war es kurz machen
bereits kalt es von mir aus beurteilt
als phantom mit von profil förderschule
oder um gottes
wissen vermittelt machen rufen als
gründe
führt jetzt aus
mittelschulen kommt
schicksalhafte minuten für rektor
steuble wird der verwaltungsrat
personelle konsequenzen beschließen
[Musik]
im weiteren verlauf der sitzung muss die
schulleitungen die versammlung verlassen
und die räte werden die vertrauensfrage
diskutieren
auch bei der abschlussklasse sexy steht
eine wichtige zäsur an klassen wäre
mario zangl verteilt das letzte
zwischenzeugnis vor der matura
zum zeugen und die absenzen eingetragen
und einige haben dabei bemerkungen was
stehen wie es dann gleich sehen werden
wegen der promotion und auch wegen des
schulischen
sagen wir dann benehmen
aufgrund von verspätungen und und
ähnlichem
hatte
ja von unten gerechnet
batliner
schon im schnitt an kompensation
ein schüler trifft mit verspätung ein
wegen einer sportveranstaltung
entschuldigt ist robin schäfer wiederum
hat einen termin bei der schulleitung
lehrer zankl erklärt dem schüler das in
seinem zeugnis der bemerkung
schadenswert eingetragen ist
bei ein paar anderen schieben
antrag in der in der konferenz noten
konferenz vom mittwoch
ja ja so einen großen und ganz meiner
davis jr perfektes beispiel geliefert
und ist da eingetrudelt mit 15 minuten
verspätung sind nichts neues also nicht
mehr zu ändern nur neun millionen
verschwinden ja das handy werde
natürlich sicher auch einen tat uns wert
des themas
das ist
aber okay sein wünscht
nachmittag
da haben wir eine perfekte ist besser
selbst
[Applaus]
bei matt leider sieht es gut aus für die
matura in fünf monaten
kritischer wird es für sie war
wenn seine matura arbeit nicht
akzeptiert wird darf er auch nicht an
die abschlussprüfungen er hat deshalb
einen termin bei prorektor kurt leitl
[Musik]
projektleiter ist zuständig für die
schulischen belange der gymnasiasten
bist du ja ich habe schon eigentlich
alles ich habe noch geld und geschichte
aber ich denke ich hab nicht geschickt
worden ja aber ich heute also du bist
fertig ist möchte meinung oder ja ich
habe schon alles geschickt vielleicht
sagt er das ist falsch dann mache ich
nun etwas anderes und dann vielleicht
sagt er das ist zum beispiel ganz nicht
richtig jedes bisschen solche welle hat
diese kurve gekratzt ja und dann zeigen
die stadt gut aus du wirst also sehr
viel lernen müssen werden
ja
hast du musst du musst du schon sehr
anstrengend jetzt im zweiten semester
und vor allen dingen zum beispiel
regelmäßig in den unterricht gehen
diese ausrede maturarbeit haus nicht
mehr leer ist vorbei
okay
die matura arbeitet sie war gerade noch
hinbekommen doch mit den schlechten
zeugnis 20 größeres unheil an
irgendwie die realität wie man früher
gesagt das ist eigentlich recht ist dass
sich sehr anstrengen muss hat auch ganz
verdrängt weil er ein schlechtes zeugnis
kannst doch nicht geben
der schweiz weit weg von gut und böse
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht was eine wer denkt
rektor gerhard stäbler ist nicht mehr an
der sitzung des verwaltungsrates dieser
berät hinter verschlossenen türen und
bespricht die arbeit der schulleitung
schäuble bringt jeweils den
verwaltungsratspräsidenten professor
doktor rolf dubs mit seinem auto nach
spuren zum bahnhof
[Musik]
im verlauf der autofahrt wird schäuble
von vr-präsident typs über die letzten
entscheidungen des verwaltungsrats
orientiert
schäuble weiß dass das gremium vor
wenigen minuten auch über ihn und seine
prorektoren gesprochen hat
[Musik]
während der zehnminütigen fahrt runter
nach spiel erfährt rektor gerhard
steuble ob der verwaltungsrat
konsequenzen für ihn und die übrige
schulleitung beschlossen hat
in der nächsten sendung der
internatsschule dann schreitet rektor
steuble zur schwierigsten rede seiner
amtszeit
auch bei silber puschkin überschlagen
sich die ereignisse
er fliegt zurück nach russland
denkt
und matt liner graudenz trifft auf einen
superstar
olympiasieger dario cologna leitet ein
langlauftraining und besucht das
internat in welchem er vier jahre lang
wohnte
[Musik]